okay uh to end it off though i i gotta
point out this blast for me right here
yeah uh you gave the first pokemon movie
yep newton or yaksu
a four out of ten yeah yeah yeah your
[ __ ] nostalgia are you seriously
telling me the
the [ __ ] third movie the
more than the first [ __ ] pokemon
movie i honestly i watched them as a kid
and i think i remember the
entei movie more i don't [ __ ] give a
[ __ ] about pokemon guys
honestly honestly this is all nostalgia
talking here
i've i'm i'm talking i rated this as an
adult or a teenager
like yeah years [ __ ] after pokemon
man
like get get your nostalgia talk out of
here pokemon wasn't that great
it's just i
digimon is better than pokemon i will
fight you on this
i i was the digimon kid digimon the
first movie
was [ __ ] brilliant did you have an
amazing soundtrack the digimon kid is
like the og neighbors kid you know what
i mean
that that meme of like oh go and look
after the neighbor's kid oh is he weird
yeah it's like he's a digimon it's a
digimon fan you know
i bet you were the kind of kid who was
like i don't play yu-gi-oh i play duel
masters
refuses to duel without the brakes yeah
exactly
no wait did you did either of you watch
digimon yeah i did
so you so i only watched i only watched
the movies okay but are you are you
still sticking by the player
i mean i watched them both at the same
age and i preferred pokemon really
yeah because digimon's digimon had an
actual plot
okay i think at that age that wasn't my
concern yeah
i think i think at that age the concern
is which monsters look cool
i think i think the thing was right is
that i would watch pokemon and then go
play pokemon and be like yo this is
exactly
exactly i would play digimon go and play
one of the [ __ ] disgusting rpg games
they have that was impossible to fit did
you have you ever played that yeah
like 10 year old me was stuck on the
[ __ ] thing like the first level i
couldn't do anything and i'm like what
sick
[ __ ] made this for a children's tv show
yeah because the thing the thing about
digimon and pokemon is that i never gave
a [ __ ] about the games
right right i didn't really i didn't
really care about the pokemon game
i actually watched the pokemon anime
years before like i played the actual
games for the first time
really and the thing that stuck out to
me for digimon was that even as a kid i
could recognize that this had story arcs
you know like like like even as a kid
i'm just like what
you are the most pretentious [ __ ] no
no no i was just this kid in his [ __ ]
diapers
in his phone like raping me on his mouth
turn this pokemon show off i i want
story in my children's shows
because i was always thinking to myself
why is ash not getting anywhere in his
life
i was angry about that as well everyone
was angry about that but the mewtwo
movie
yeah i was good that had [ __ ] fanta
mewtwo was a fantastic [ __ ] character
like you could relate to that guy so
[ __ ] hard and then you know with the
whole like you can't tell me that
you didn't cry i don't know when you
watched the first pokemon
you did not you can't tell me you didn't
cry with the pikachu crying scene
i never gave a [ __ ] about pikachu you're
dead to me i know i never give a [ __ ]
about ash
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's it's it's a loud
[ __ ] yellow rat guys get over
yourself
jesus christ
diabetic dinosaur i would i would insult
digimon but it's so
[ __ ] forgettable that i can't even
remember anything i can only remember
what a [ __ ] name agumon what is that
yeah all i'm saying
is digimon was the original isekai
of course i'm going to rip digimon
i i was born out my mom's woman i'm just
like mother
is this a new world yes it is i'm
[ __ ] um
i love i love my digimon and as a kid
digimon
was a bet is a better story than pokemon
and i will i would hey guys make sure to
uh follow us on the trash taste twitter
to just absolutely [ __ ] all over this
man's opinions